seemingly impossible stunts an excessive
amount of jet fuel and a co-star with a
death wish miles teller wasn't prepared
for tom cruise's response to an
unexpected health scare top gun maverick
continues to dominate at the box office
it was a force to be reckoned with when
it first came out breaking a record at
the box office for the largest haul ever
over memorial day weekend since then the
flick has broken yet another record by
becoming the highest grossing film of
2022 at the domestic box office
surpassing even marvel studios doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
it's abundantly clear that audiences
have a need a need for speed and top gun
maverick is fulfilling that need part of
the reason the movie's been such a hit
with critics and audiences alike is that
it's obvious that everyone involved is
giving their all in fact much of the
cast learned how to actually respond to
being in a fighter jet to shoot the
film's aerial sequences while this might
sound like fun and games things got a
little hairy on set for miles teller as
he revealed in an interview on late
night with seth meyers in fact myers
brought up how teller had an allergic
reaction at one point while filming top
gun maverick and the story behind it
sounds pretty scary so we landed
i'm just like man i'm not feeling too
good and i was like getting i was really
hot and i just started itching like
crazy
teller went on to explain that when he
got out of the jet he was covered in
hives all over his body after going to
see a doctor and having a blood analysis
done it turned out that teller had
chemicals from the jets in his blood
including pesticides flame retardant and
jet fuel finding out all the substances
are in your body may be concerning to
some but teller says he thought it was
actually pretty cool the actor decided
to reveal the diagnosis to his famous
co-star tom cruise explaining that
doctors had literally found jet fuel in
his blood unsurprisingly cruz had the
most awesome response ever and without
even skipping a beat tom just goes yeah
i was born with a kid
honestly we'd expect nothing less from
tom cruise and considering the fact that
the mission impossible star does many of
his own stunts in his films we wouldn't
be surprised at all to hear he's
actually part machine not only that but
there's some truth to the claim as cruz
has held a pilot's license since 1994.
as the movie star has proven once again
with the release of top gun maverick
he's a true blue action star who knows
what it's like to get worrying news from
a doctor it goes without saying that
teller's scooping up some contaminants
in his blood is certainly scary but no
doubt the reason cruz took the news in
stride was because he knows what it's
like to suffer for one's art the actor
famously enjoys doing his own stunts and
while it makes for more thrilling
sequences it also puts him in harm's way
and he's gotten injured more than a few
times while shooting most recently and
perhaps famously crews suffered from a
broken ankle while filming mission
impossible fallout he was doing a stunt
that required him to jump from one
building rooftop to the next hitting the
side of the wall in the process during
the stunt he broke his ankle which
reportedly put him out of commission for
filming for several weeks it wasn't the
first time the mission impossible
franchise bruised cruz up a bit either
during the exploding fish tank sequence
in the first mission impossible the
actor apparently twisted his ankle and
suffered a few cuts on his legs in the
process and those weren't even the
scariest stunts cruz has ever pulled off
the actor has almost died for his art on
several occasions including one instance
while filming the last samurai during
one particular scene a mechanical horse
malfunctioned bumping crews and causing
him to get awfully close to a sword
which reportedly came a mere half inch
from the actor's neck this is only a
small sampling of the types of injuries
cruz has sustained over his long
illustrious career he's gotten plenty of
others some of which nearly ended the
actor's life here's hoping both cruz and
teller manage to keep themselves out of
trouble so they can continue
entertaining audiences for a long time
to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one